by the way i'll tell you who's met his
share of disaster is stevie blue eyes
where if you you're talking to him he
had cancer he had like you know lymphoma
how's his eye he got run over when he
was 13.
oh yeah oh he did good he was 13 like he
casually says yeah i didn't walk for a
year yeah
i'm like what he goes i got run over by
a [ __ ] car and my my legs
he's had some hard times yeah very damn
yeah cancer
stung in the [ __ ] eye by a hornet
went while going through chemo yeah
good stuff wait that's a real story oh
yeah he's in the back seat of his
[ __ ] the air conditioning breaks down
in dog days of summer
boston in traffic his eighth month of
chemo
and he's like you know i think i'd
rather die i'm just gonna die this is no
good
he goes and he's lying in the back seat
there's no air conditioning
traffic he's here in august and he's on
chemo that's a great time because when
you when you're done with your drip
that's when you're the sickest
he's lying there like this and he's like
i think i just i think it'd be good if i
just died now i just wanted 17 cool
stories a wasp
goes do you mind if i just come in and
sing you here in your eyeball eyeball
and then you already said he goes no
matter how bad you think it is it can
always be worth it
what's tom marrero say even rock bottom
has a little wiggle room
i don't know we never heard that story
that's pretty funny that's tom's joke
yeah that's a great it's like even rock
bottom has a little wiggle room
that's true [ __ ] are you ready tim oh
it's gone oh we're going yeah
i've decided you are you are somebody
i have to be your beefcake you're a
beefcake but i'm a little afraid of you
now only because i feel like your
nicotine is a habit
and if you don't have it you could get
you can get shoving feisty
you might get chevy because you even
said to me you go
let's do a video and we'll grapple yes
and i went
i don't like i've never had to say that
you didn't want to do it
yeah you said i got to go to the airport
then i said you're up for a little bit
of scuffle i'm up for a little scuffle
still am
i'm i'm down for scuffling right but not
when you're not watching because your
duck duck go shirt bothers me
does that mean you want to be too old to
be wearing that though if you want to
take your necklace off and get crazy we
can get crazy
three on but i'll take one off now you
take three off you want to take all
three off no you know why
do you have a flat earth shirt too or
how does this work no dude i just
they sent these to me and i haven't seen
it because nobody wears them and i like
to wear it because nobody wears
i like the way they fit because they hug
my shoulders now have you ever used the
site
[Laughter]
who uses it well here's the thing i've
used this site a couple times after i
read the madison crowds
because google tends to be very very
woke yeah and they'll
send you no they're gonna send you ads
oh my god
hey and they're gonna track what you're
watching let me just
let him explain the sights i know him i
know he is right he's not
uses it but like a lot of computer guys
use it it's like the dark web guy shows
me you got to go through
it i'm out i'm not a router i'm like i'm
never doing it
dark web
all the cyber stuff for the fbi he's
like
they have contractors think i go can't
track the dark web he goes
what come again you think the fbi can't
track your [ __ ] oh you don't yeah you
can't oh you think those guys that built
that are smarter than our government
officials
they attract you they hire hackers they
hire those yeah they highlight oh
got it you know they should have did
that for that dude oh no
no
he's in prison for the rest of his life
but why not convert him to a government
because he he [ __ ] he did try and
murder two people though yeah oh
can't have you okay you can't do that
can't do that but you talk to stevie
who's afraid he's like he didn't kill
anybody i'm like
that's not the point for all he knows is
those people were murdered because he
hired him to be murdered
but they he was talking to government
undercover cops and they went jobs done
he went
hell yeah so we got to put him away bad
guy yeah all right that's more guy
though smarter guy
maybe he could work for us in his
cubicle now speaking of drugs in the
underground
i the other thing is i feel like if if
there's a shortage of nicotine or
whatever else you're taking if they're
short of nicotine daddy's gonna pull
your teeth out yeah because
when we were walking across the street
he's never done this and i don't know if
it does i said
i said something and he goes now if you
ask me that again i'm gonna punch you in
the face
it was aggressive and i went but he's
but he's asked the same thing
nine times every time i see him he said
it the same thing like dude if you keep
going this route i'm going to hurt you
but have you given him an
answer yes yeah the answer is clear it's
as clear as dave oh okay
it's the same [ __ ] why do you keep
asking can i be honest with you not
hitting me in the face is i'm a cobra
my head never stops moving and you know
that and i swear to god
you know who can hit you in the face
shane carwin shane
shane could squeeze because that is this
now shane he's never met shane now
shane's hands because they're swollen
because papa's off the diet
you saw him his hands are bigger
and by the way still still in shape he
does not have a tummy at all
he's a big he's look at that look at
this he wears a eight and one fourth hat
he has to get custom made
i put it on i look like well like when
those little bobble held
yeah like it was like it was so big he
was texting me and
i didn't know what he was oh you know
how he attacked
sorry my fat fingers won't i can't
text with my fat fingers i was like well
they're the biggest hands in the ufc
biggest hands up yeah but you said he
had the he had the biggest gloves still
does yeah biggest glove
he squeezed he had to custom make him
like there's like triple and then his
they have to like custom make for his
fights yeah he he picked me up and
squeezed me
and then i i started to tap and he goes
that's 40 percent
and for real and then i and then i was
like oh my god and then nate marquart
who at the time was the strikeforce
champion oh my god look at him yeah he
looked at me and he goes uh don't worry
he can do that to me too
yeah he's so huge and he's a guy he's
got some blue eyes
yeah a little dodgy i didn't realize his
eyes lives right outside houston now
yeah he lives right outside houston he's
a [ __ ] monster
he was a monstar we shot some guns in
texas doug oh you did
some real guns bob you did like shot at
ak-47 what else
some ao i don't know now how loud is
that and how much of a kick does an ak
have it's really hard to be accurate
with an ak
yeah listen i'm not trying to win any
[ __ ] awards there you are look at you
this is me shooting i had to get
headphones now could you
be anymore yeah you are a 100
and i'm not trying to be you are one
hundred percent ethnically
i do look you're like i'm part of the
you're there yeah
yeah yeah no you're you're a mexican man
yes and we should do your genome i know
you've done it but i think they screwed
things up you're 100 mexican there
the ak-47 wasn't that hard to hard to
fire
that look near that little that smaller
one well they had a handheld automatic
that just went [ __ ] that one
that one helped oh there was one call
in the video it's an uzi no no
we did that we did all the guns but you
know what after 30 minutes i'm good
yeah it does it does get exhausting i
shall shot one gun so was it was it a
range if it's a range of super boring
range if you have a
at taren tactical at least it's like a
it's like an obstacle course you're
moving around
well they wanted to do that with us but
um it was raining weather
it was raining we could we had to go to
a range but still i mean
this h uh what htx tactical is cool
because that get the owner there was a
b-boy
so he kind of mixes like that kind of
hip-hop
like vibe vibes with the guns that's his
car
so yeah they do a lot of custom uh
what's he do that guy owns a gun
and he just has a rolls royce yeah yeah
they're big time
huh big big time all right yeah we're
shooting zombies yeah i
had to run out whoa what the [ __ ] is
this well this is texas
that's an mp5 no that's
not that one i'm holding it right there
all right not that one
it's the one i'm holding keep that okay
keep going just let play chin
that one no that's the nope that's not
it you're not talking
they're illegal in california yeah it's
like the it's like it's a handgun but it
has that little shoulder
adjustable socket yeah that thing was
[ __ ]
nine millimeters and you're like jesus
could you hold it because a lot of times
you get you kick up
i try to shoot a saw with an m60 which
it's got a belt
and you smell ammonia when you shoot it
m60 what is that it's a machine gun
it's like a yeah it's like what you have
so on the
the roofs of the embassies you'd have
that to clear out a crowd like
if it gets the [ __ ] gets crazy and that
the [ __ ] thing
they like it goes up though i would try
to shoot it it would
it would kick up and like the only gun
i've had an issue with where i
really had to like [ __ ] really get
into it was the desert eagle
yeah those are 50 calisthenics now
that's the only time decal yeah that's
the only time i had to like spread my
feet and like brace myself these other
guns never
that bullet was originally my
grandfather told me this he was a navy
guy
though the desert eagle 50 cow that
caliber was
originally designed as an anti-aircraft
anti-tank bullet
it's it's heavy yeah i don't know how
about matt best one hand
with a desert eagle yeah that best is
jack armstrong all-american captain
america he's captain america he's the
real captain america how about i send a
picture to uh tim kennedy shooting the
ak-47 he said throw that thing in the
[ __ ] trash
when i said uh not for guys like him
when i left when i left the podcast tim
was tim was sitting down
and he goes hey [ __ ] and i look over
and he's sitting there staring at me
with those
shark eyes those dead and he gets up and
he goes like this
he just first thing he does takes me in
with his hands yeah i'm wearing a tight
shirt and he goes
not bad he's so funny
when i saw him i go you're in shape he
goes i am in shape
i go damn man you're in shape because i
am in shape i was like okay
well he doesn't fight he wasn't oh
you see him with a shirt off daddy no
he's monster yeah what he's doing now is
tougher than what he did in usc remember
when i told you i was going to roll with
him and you thought i was serious could
i go i'm going to challenge him to
wrestle get up and you went
no like that like you you were a bad
idea i was like no i'm just [ __ ]
around don't do it he's a man speaking
of dope fighters
my boy uh oh my god chappelle won't shut
up about this guy
it's playoff time but baba nba playoffs
big stakes
bigger promotions we talking about
draftkings sportsbook it's putting you
on courtside with a chance to turn
five dollars into two hundred dollars
that's 40 to one odds
on any playoff basketball game all you
have to do is pick any team
that is still in the hunt all right
that's right pick any team that's still
in contention
to win it all bet five dollars if that
team wins you cash
two hundred dollars in free credits all
it takes to claim these 40 to one odds
on the basketball team of your choosing
is placing a five dollar bet on the team
and that team has to win don't forget
draftking sportsbook also offers great
odds
on baseball hockey fighting ufc
boxing we got it all man draftkings is
safe secure reliable so you can deposit
and withdraw your funds
whenever you want download the top rated
draftkings sportsbook now
and use promo code fighter when you sign
up to turn five dollars and 200 dollars
in free credits bet on the basketball
team of your choice to win their next
game if they do
you claim 200 in free credits that's
promo code fighter
for limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook must be 21 and older new
jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only wager paid out and site credits
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gaming problem
call 100 gambler indiana 109 with it
hey man remember we're in high school
trying to learn a second language it was
a beast we're in college what are we
doing
now thanks to babble i can
cypher out what my kid is talking trash
for me in spanish because babel is the
number one selling language learning app
all right it's fun it's easy to learn a
new language with babel babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons
that you actually use in the real world
i took french for four years in high
school i don't understand
any of it complete waste of time babel
came along
listen 15-minute lessons make it a
perfect way to learn language on the go
babel designs their courses with
practical real-world conversations
in mind all right they're going to get
you ready man uh
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts all right
with babble you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german
your boys learn spanish right now with
babel all right right now when you
purchase a three month babel
subscription you get
an additional three months free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com
use the promo code fighter that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code is fighter for an extra three
months free babble language for life
don't do it he's a man speaking of dope
fighters my boy uh oh my god chappelle
won't shut up about this guy
this guy we're on the road we just send
the airbnb and watch youtube videos
and chappelle brought up this guy what's
his name shinigami
he is the best thing we do see this guy
now brian i'm gonna ask you before you
see it
do you when you do see him do you think
he's got this guy no go to no no
a street beefs street beefs there it is
shinigami
go to that one that top
that's the guy no that's a guy come on
now
keep that same energy same energy now
they're fighting
on hay but be cool yeah be cool now it's
a good road and they put out hay
okay now now notice he has a black belt
on and a bandana
because he's a black belt wow watch
brian watch him work
for his size
[Applause]
[Music]
come i love watching street beefs
because they're like shout out to my
sponsors and they're like
he's like shout out to my kids wife
friend andrew what's up dog told you i
was gonna make it man
here we go here and he's and he always
bows
uh i don't know who that is yeah should
have got me no i'm not i'm not gonna lie
a lot
yeah he fights a lot he fights a lot now
it gets a little dicey if it goes past a
minute because if it goes all right now
yeah that's the thing about
spoiler alert bad cardio cardio cardio
strong asset did you guys watch the
fights this weekend oh [ __ ] of course
okay well here we go who is uh that
[ __ ]
fight yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] the pros
we're talking about not sure what to do
here with the single legs
he's trying to look at him look at him
there you go
oh boy but look what he did oh oh
kimura no oh there you go oh hi
here we are now they're they're fighting
uh great to roll on this stuff yeah
fight on gravel it's good to get it in
your skin too it's
they're no tetanus oh just oh no they
keep going chin
fast forward it you what this is the
thing about him it's either a knockout
or it's
very boring there's no one in between
i can literally watch his fights all day
okay he lost due to
oh no that's like his first loss i think
it's his only loss it's like matt search
you know what though
i think he's i think he's like twenty
and one he lost a big second if i'd say
he lost
his kids at least shinigami isn't he
great is he great
he's getting in there you're great thank
you i i give him i support this he's
fighting he's really fighting i get
anybody who gets into a [ __ ]
pit like i found out he sells merch too
and me and chappelle are going to buy
something oh yeah i'm buying his money
i 100 want a t-shirt you guys should
probably maybe i should get him on food
truck wait what's his instagram
not a lot of people find it yeah but he
should i like him isn't he great yeah oh
he's
he's amazing i like him shinny 61 000.
um
go to the youtube clip again i think it
says on there what does shinigami mean
yeah what does that mean that first top
one good good job knowing it's japanese
i think it means out of shape
that's a nice yeah
they might be following him let's see
we're not following them they yeah they
should be following
yeah of course they're falling again
dude and where do they do these at i
would love know
you said lancaster i would love to go to
one
uh yeah yeah of course because you
wouldn't get mobbed at all
because you wouldn't have to take all
the pictures yeah right because you love
that i know he has this
definitely go to one yeah definitely go
maybe i could go in like a disguise
there he is there's my boy the reaper
the reaver the reaper mma he just cooked
steaks too
oh it you know of course it's thick
but you gotta love a guy who could give
a [ __ ] about like his weight loss he's
just like i'm a heavyweight
uh turn it up chip trains
he got me back again still here at the
lab with a very important birthday shout
out to team shinigami con zones he's
always giving shout outs 21st birthday
bro hell yeah bro get lit and have fun
in vegas bro
yeah bro uh bet it all on black
like a cameo anywhere he dude he always
wears that
is that is that wifey looks like his uh
it looks like
he's related to her yeah how dare you
having lunch with
the rachel's overdue movie and lunch
dave how about you what's this girl
how dare you girl don't you don't let me
see that video what kind of content is
he putting out we have
his content what up shinagamikai just
wanted to make a quick announcement that
i somehow have twice as many followers
on instagram as i've have subscribers on
youtube
please make sure you go subscribe to my
youtube link is in my bio or you can
just look me up it should've got me the
reaper
good judy sounds like a lot of food a
lot of
this so what is the what dude i like i
swear to god i'll buy that shirt
oh that might be my next tattoo even
though i never got sick
you don't have a tattoo no no but i like
i like his hair oh i like it
you gotta love a dude who just like he
gets let's hang out
he gets in there and fights a real kung
fu panda the streets but like
he's a street panda here's the thing
he's a street panda i
couldn't pull three pictures i could
have changed panda that's a street panda
that should be his [ __ ] street
panther reaper
no just street panda mma oh look at him
dude dude he's amazing listen i couldn't
pull off that kick
oh gina back in the day 2015.
oh this guy's in it to win it i mean
that's gotta be his girl that's a
throwback yeah that's his girl
hey shinigami rachel again with another
birthday and here's a shout out to
danny and jose hope you guys have a
blast
on this amazing occasion i wish i was a
new year's baby
that's [ __ ] awesome hey you gotta
love them
you gotta love them hey everybody happy
new years from the shinigami family
hey happy new year so he's got kids
he's got kids well she has a pentagon
tattoo so that's cool
hold on hold on we got to stop
everything
brandon good spot good spot brandon man
i think that we have to be careful about
celebrating a satanist
they're not saying this well you
wouldn't get that that too if you don't
get down with that stuff
why would you why because some people
like the way it looks okay and some
people like human sacrifice here's
don't you and some people like the nazis
how dare you treat shinigami
i don't know about that i don't judge if
that's what they're into i don't give a
[ __ ]
is she's she's she's into the darkness
no i'm gonna have to see what's going on
and
if there's any sacrifice going on and
also um
hey does it there's a heavyweight uh
limit like 265.
it's stopping he's not fighting at 265.
uh he's probably 265. no no
remember he thought you were 265. now
think how much he is true he's over 300
i spend way too much time in my brain
yeah spent way too much my brain in
tampa uh
thinking about you at 19. i'm gonna need
you to trim down
i can't there is a [ __ ] when when
michelangelo
carved the statue of david okay still
stand still in florence
it is you know one of the wonders one of
the ones he said he looked at that piece
of marble
he looked that piece of marble he called
it garnier it's meat
you know what he said he goes it's in
there
the perfect body is in there it's in you
i just gotta get all the meat you know
what i don't know
what's wrong with his body now though
you didn't see how much weight he was
pushing dude go to my go to my uh
instagram profile what did you do to go
to my store 45
uh i know 265 i know i know you're very
strong
i'm asking if i can get if i'm listening
to 19.
click on a chin this door it's in there
it's in there you reach 100k
that's want to make it reality bay
dengues
look at look at your bell but this is my
favorite thing it's your problem like
what are you doing tonight like
i'll get linking up with my bad hit next
you're in a band
yeah he's going this weekend on some big
tour bus
that's 2 35 45 your trainer is the
greatest look at his [ __ ] hair
i can't concentrate anything his hair is
on fire oh mark's the best oh he's
amazing he's
one of those uh dolls with the hair that
goes up oh the shoulders
throw trolls yes god he's a muscular
troll i love him
i got to meet him you gotta meet him he
comes on the road with me yeah
he's the best [ __ ] he's amazing i mean
he can tie his hair into a savage
screw at the top it's fire screw
dude jack dude fans get so excited when
he comes out
yeah when he comes out like to the merch
table oh dude he could keep him nice
he could keep a a stiletto he could keep
any drugs he'd keep a lot of things in
his hair
anything wow yeah even a bottle of
whiskey so back to my nights
we saw whiskey pete right and whiskey
pete goes uh how do you feel when people
uh you know accuse you of steroids
because i am there
and whiskey goes why do you guys yeah
people never ask because if you ask i'll
tell you what the [ __ ] i'm thinking yeah
he's like i don't
don't ask him he's like this is weird
thing everyone just assumes all this
[ __ ] he's like just ask me it's way
easier to get a answer if you just
what does he take i don't i don't know i
i don't care
i don't i don't know he works his ass
off yeah he's
he just looks the way he i love i love
talking to guys are you looking for his
profile
no whiskey pete oh there oh yeah
yeah he's awesome that was a fun episode
i had to take a step back
because uh i was smelling that whiskey a
lot and i was like i'm gonna go sit
yeah you almost relapse huh yeah like
somebody
you're yourself i'm a whiskey guy he
likes to smell it though yeah
he smells it but i was smelling a lot
and
it was like yeah a little too much yeah
a little too much
most of the time i'm like good but i was
like oh damn that smells too good
let's get let's get let's get back to
the david let's get back to this oh yeah
so
they called it connect you have to get
all the meat out of the way
and it's there that that's how you look
at art or your life get rid of all the
stuff around you
and find your best self you don't be too
skinny though no but he wasn't too
scared that's what i was saying
he was jackie take your shirt off
contest
what picture did you see with me that
was skinny the one we pulled up last
time
you went like second in a dance contest
some [ __ ] it in a dance concert
beauty i'm not gonna remember we did a
back flap backflip in houston
in your ass popped out yeah you know
people
he yelled for only certain amount of
people could see go to his go to his
way the way
no that's the one your ass popped up no
no it was the the second night here
you get some you got some air look at
that look at the air it is pretty funny
whoa look at that i'll send it to you
dude that's because it's pretty funny it
looks like a goddamn drake concert
because everybody gets their phones out
oh yes on this video
basketball but would you want it i mean
i can't dunk a basketball here this is
right here
look at all the [ __ ] camera phones
out
i'm too big look at that you're right
no you're not you look fine i just would
like to watch now i'm walking up through
the back and you'll see his ass pop out
the top yeah i think might
you just see my crack hey don't judge me
[Laughter]
hey you don't slow down on the crack and
i got up there and roast his ass i know
right
yeah hey how long are we over 10 spills
i said how long would you pretend
pop out okay
look at it you get
[Laughter]
that's horrible i need to stop doing it
i'm not doing it anymore yeah you want
you don't
want to say that i no i didn't say that
no you always say you're never doing
them
but sometimes when the crowds are that
lit you got to do it man i'm telling you
those shows the best crowds we've ever
had
in houston it was insane
what did what did what did david say oh
he goes everybody walked out with two
guns everybody was just
i think that's what he said you know
david david's amazing yeah
you haven't met david no i don't think
so dude i love him too yeah
he's like the worst person that anybody
wants to heckle
oh some girl hellcat we're all waiting
he just well he's a professional roaster
[ __ ] and some girl said something and
then he's all and we're and we're all
just we poke our heads
yeah he's just like i might be the worst
roaster of all time because i don't want
to hurt anybody's feelings
yeah you don't like you're like you you
you're yeah how do you deal with a heck
out
of
it
i just like acknowledge them and then
just let them know that you care about
them
and then david's like [ __ ] that man
people the [ __ ]
it works better yeah it works and but
like literally everyone shuts up because
he
gets people so it's so disrespectful
yeah
i'm more like brogan david now like we
had we had someone in the front row and
i was like [ __ ] you want to keep doing
this you really want to do this
he just left i never rogan oh yeah
yeah i don't get uh i rarely suffer from
heckling but
yeah i don't know you don't seem like
you get a lot i just i just even if i
got an opening it's like i'm the kind of
guy if i'm playing a board game with you
and you really want to win if you're
super competitive
i'm like all right hey yeah i see that
you let uh
dylan um black dude dylan uh in tampa
yeah you gave him a spot yeah cool dude
he's a great kid
he's not the kid he's great yeah
dylan walker i follow him if you're
trying to find us
but like yeah good dude i got so roasted
for posting [ __ ] blurry pictures
some fan did that and christian was like
it was my fault chris was like you
should post that for fan interaction i'm
like okay
way to go brian look how blurry it
the worst pigs i've is seen well they
sure are because you can't even
sacrifice a great pick brandon him i
mean you look like you it's like i'm
under water
the person who took the pictures they
took good pictures of them
i don't know what you did to those
pictures but they didn't
happy birthday young man and he's just
getting lit
secrets when you have a very high
quality photo if you upload it onto
instagram directly they decompress it so
it looks shitty you have to go through
another app there's a whole tooltip
i can't even look at my face anymore i
know i was watching some of your mad tv
stuff i have to apologize for my face
now
i'm getting oh damn so so brandon uh
reposted it
high quality though yeah well original
post hey
hey let's wait can we acknowledge it
look at him look at this all right
it's called the spread bro it's called a
laugh yeah it's called spread
it's freaking insane yeah it's from
years just training so you're trying to
get me down to your body
you don't i was just very impressed with
what you had what you were working into
he was 19.
yeah it's 30 something okay
let's see your body i'm 34. you look
exactly the same
okay you've never looked different all
the years i've known you you've never
even when you're doing that power lift
heart you've always looked exactly
to a t the same i stayed no matter what
yeah and now i'm like every time and
i'll be like this i'm like oh
you know what i'm gonna do and start
bodybuilding i'm gonna start no no
because now i'm gonna
you know i just can't i can't i can't
maui was [ __ ] beautiful it's nice huh
yeah wide open
it's pretty open everybody still wears
uh
masks but it wasn't that big uh i don't
know if there's a mandate the only thing
is it's really strict getting into
hawaii you get there you have to do a
covet test 72 hours before you do an
instant kova test when you're there i'm
out
yeah it's pretty strict and then the
airport takes forever if you're
vaccinated
if you're vaccinating you can kind of
bypass through that but you still go
through each of the little checkpoints
show your vaccination card and then you
dip you know who doesn't give a [ __ ]
is tampa during pride gay pride
uh day yeah when they 40 000 people were
you there
you know that that's that that stretch
where people drive by
in their cars and blast music well 40
000 people descended
on ebor city and and nobody was wearing
a mask and it was just like wow that's
florida
in houston a lot of people had masked
them but there's no mass mandate so they
can't force
them so like we went to the mall packed
maul the galleria nobody
no a lot of people are in mass but it's
up to that's how it should be like yeah
all right if you're not vaccinated or
you want to wear math [ __ ] win
do you want the rest of you do whatever
you want all right not one
i talked to a cop and i said the worst
shirt i've ever seen well it was
like that gay pride stuff in in tampa
was unbelievable everybody you were so
nice
everybody was just happy with the guys
nice to meet you
yeah everybody was so nice of course
i was wearing chats yeah but the thing
is but the cop said to me he goes
we didn't i asked him maybe he's wrong
but he goes we didn't have one violent
not
one problem no i mean who i mean they're
all happy gays ain't trying to fight
yeah trying to have fun it was just oh
look at that
now is that is it nationwide gay pride
stuff
i think june is gabriel because la's big
too
yeah but i think it's june that's good i
think it's coming up right yeah
naked people june is gay pride month
yeah yeah you guys call your best friend
brandon uh brian should know i mean
what's that
i was not christian i was not i happened
to have walked
through when i was going to my show
and i met some college guys i don't know
why
hey brian also no i'm gay because i was
in tampa and i got a little drunk
same time you are the big gay owl so i
am the best you're like their mascot
i always you should dress up as an owl
with your ass out
you could have done it
who wants me who wants to turn me into
do whatever do you guys do what'd you
guys do in hawaii
we chilled for the first day there the
last day there and we did the road to
hana which is basically we
took a jeep and we drove all around the
island to get to a waterfall
yep it's really yeah is it this one
right here yeah we hiked
i'd say two hours up a mountain to get
to
that waterfall it's too long it's good
though it's good flight to hawaii
uh five hours to hawaii and then four
hours back
oh brandon no no no hawaii can do i
can't do florida and east coast for that
long
yeah or like when you come back from new
york we're going there it's like five
and change
and then we're like we got a six and a
half hour flight like cool [ __ ]
you could be in [ __ ] life but hawaii
five i can deal with
yeah cause it feels like you're here in
new york six going back to six we're
headed into the tailwinds it's such a
[ __ ]
came out chicago was four and a half
yeah i mean
the longest was and i flew first class
with like on thai airways or something
going to thailand it's a nightmare oh
dude isn't that like 16 hours oh my god
it's well it's by the time you get there
you're older yeah
no you you get a full day i got to japan
yeah and i've been in a plane and i'm
talking about
i was so directs right i could lie down
i was this was
i was literally my whole body i was
trying to walk 18 hours
and 30 minutes on top of powers yeah but
long you're literally on the flight that
long yes dude
flying it's longer because you stop in
japan then you have this layover and
then you get on another i'd rather stop
in japan
two days in japan then go to yeah the
pilot
yeah but you know then it then again
your clock is so screwed up
so you get there and it's like tuesday
and you're on monday it's the whole
thing is a [ __ ]
no how how far was australia how long
would you do it 14
16 14. it felt long but let's see i
think it's only 14.
you go from uh atlanta to
what does it say it doesn't say i hate
how this freaking advertising stuff pops
up
right away now see that yeah and it
messes it up
[Music]
15. yeah it was a long time
17 hours sydney's 17 hours there's no
layover
uh we had a layover in atlanta got it
okay so it's like this one says
five hours south africa was 16 hours it
was a nightmare it was just too long
it's so long it's too long so long what
do you do i
you you take drugs and passions stew you
stir
you stew you sleep if you're in first
class you lay out yeah then you're like
not everyone not everyone you're in
first yeah
other people just got to do if you're in
first class you're [ __ ] 18 hours like
this dude yeah dude and then you're like
this you're like
oh man how much longer i bet you this is
crazy my back
eight more hours yeah halfway oh i don't
need to see them yeah
it's a lot then and then you're gonna
get oh by the way though but come on
then you gotta go through customs and
let's be honest
you're in a van or something for another
hour and a half to get to where you're
going it's such a wait what's it to
london
i'll do that london manchester united
five hours yeah it's easy
you go to new york you stop in new york
then fly from there you used to be three
hours of the concord
or something yeah how far is it ten
hours
five hours 10 hours 30 minutes easy it
says 10 hours
10 hours 30 minutes that's not well not
from la to london
yeah where we go well we said for if
from new york new york london
it's five yeah that's easy flight oops
yeah no your europe's not too bad when
you start going to australia
thailand that's where it gets tough yeah
18 hours yeah but in first class you
have like a straight up little room you
know the bed you lay down you watch all
the movies in the world but people get
good food you get drunk it's kind of fun
you know what they're trying to do
is i think elon musk or something
they're trying to come up with flat
where you can travel in a plane
you shoot out of the atmosphere let the
earth
go like this and the earth revolves and
you come straight down and you land
so in other words you can get from here
to china in an hour you could work in
china and live here
yeah that's terrorists are like how
about that
yeah yeah that's what they're working on
yeah i'll just spend that 18 hours
if you believe in flat earth it's not
for you but if you if you if you believe
in science
and yeah yeah that's what i was going to
say what about the flat earth the flat
earthers they have to go straight
there's nothing they've got to do
they've got to do 18 hours
and also they'll tell you that you know
this is a huge lie anyway and that
everybody from einstein to elon musk are
liars and that
they think einstein's a lion called
science scientism oh well what the what
the guy say on
uh rogan he oh he had a great joke for
conspiracy theorists he goes oh
have you heard the joke about the
conspiracy there's dies gets to heaven
he sees god
and uh you know he's talking to god and
he goes hey is the earth round and god
goes
of course it's round and the conspiracy
theorist goes
this is a much bigger uh deal than i
thought
they said much better oh no he goes this
goes this goes even bigger than i
thought
like nothing's ever gonna nothing like
even the guy's talking to god and he's
like yeah i'm created
it's round and goes oh wow this goes
beyond god
i got i guess i gotta talk to a flat
earther but you don't
don't waste your life you can spend your
time sometimes you got to hear people
out
do you just google it right just just
youtube it
you're right i don't need to they're not
all ideas are equal
not all ideas are equal right i know
myself
you know why my cell phone works yeah i
don't know just a lot of math
and a lot of exact science that went
into the fact that i can call
china yeah across all that flat land and
and
talk to somebody right so you don't get
to have it both ways when you when you
when you have
science that actually works when you can
gene edit and save lives there's
science actually is something that you
can apply
yeah and you can get tangible results
you can have measurable results
and the first rule in science is doubt
and also always be ready to change your
theory if something a better theory
comes along
i wonder who it was that just came along
and tried to debunk all the scientists
the flat earthers they've always been
around now though with social media they
can
they're just a little louder well well
now they can't they can they can be in a
group now yeah
like you you can get joining oh they
were like hey i got people backing me up
on this
it's fun though some conspiracies
some of the experiences come true
sometimes conspiracy is like well i
thought
i thought the carotid virus came from
[ __ ] bats and they were always saying
at least from a lab guess what even
fauci says yeah yeah they found out two
uh scientists that were in that lab got
sick in 2015 from it yeah
so you know now even though he's like
well maybe it did
this not i what i like about conspiracy
theorists they don't trust the
government
and they don't trust mainstream media i
don't think that i don't need a bad
thing
but i don't either i mean you should
just be responsible for the evidence
though you gotta
yeah sometimes they're not as careful
with their evidence the problem is some
conspiracies do exist
so then they think all of them exist 100
percent i get it
because i usually go hard about life all
of us have like the one thing to always
always be aware of as a human being i
don't give a [ __ ] who you are
and all the science backs this up you
have a preconceived
set of of uh uh intuitions
yeah opinions right you you believe
certain things we all have a belief
system it's hard to take
most of them right now
most of our belief system comes not from
like what we do is we
find evidence to confirm supportive yeah
believe anything that's social
confirmation that's where social media
and just be aware that you do that so i
look for stories i do that we all do it
i look for stories that that confirm
how i emotionally already lean yeah
i used to i used to get super annoyed
with like conspiracy theorists but then
i'm
like lined up on i don't care because
i'm like no if that's what they like
yeah it's like yeah and i was like
studying they did with the identical
twins
who were separated at birth where they
looked at like identical twins yeah and
they had totally up different
upbringings
but when they would go and ask them
their political points of view they they
almost always lean the same way so a lot
of times leaning left leaning right
is a personality thing yeah that makes
sense yeah because you know like
like being left tends to be wait you
said they had a different opportunity
yeah they didn't know each other yeah
and so there's a lot of
personality traits that will push you
one direction or enough yeah
it's not a bad thing no it's like i
think jordan peterson said that you need
people on the right and you need people
on the left and people on the left are
there to catch people who fall through
the cracks
like a lot of times left people on the
left are looking for the disenfranchised
the marginalized
people on the right tend to be more
about competition it's just a different
thing
you know you're welcome everybody no
hey brian be dropping that knowledge
i'll just be listening
all right ice field drained man
after working out after doing jiu jitsu
not anymore
i love true nigerian true nigerian fuels
the body's energy
engines maintain cellular metabolism and
even supports
heart health i have more energy right
now with 11 published human clinical
studies
backed by nobel prize winners true
nigerian is a supplement that's
clinically proven
to boost nad levels and the essential
coenzyme required for cellular energy
and repair
since true niogen it helps my muscle
recover after workout i use after every
workout all right
uh right now new customers can save 10
off their first purchase by going to
trueniogen.com
fighter use the code fighter that's
t-r-u-n-i-a-g-e-n
dot com slash fighter code fighter to
save 10 off your first
purchase truenigen.com fighter code
fighter
these statements have not been available
by the food and drug administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat
or prevent any disease true nigerian.com
fighter
okay so a tick-tock flyer went viral
it's this guy named adrian somewhere in
huntington beach he just made a random
flyer saying like
hey my birthday is coming up i'm going
to celebrate it on
friday yeah like friday through saturday
it's going to be a kickback
and it's going to be at huntington beach
he uh said pier 13
is where everyone's going to meet it's
just a random guy random kid in
huntington
oh my god stevie asked me this yesterday
i don't know what it was either i think
it's a west coast thing then unless you
guys are just older
it's like a more lounge type party party
yeah you're just hanging out
yeah exactly yeah what happened was this
tick tock went viral and 200 million
people saw it
and 2 500 people showed up to huntington
beach on friday and saturday to party
and it was so crazy that uh the police
actually had to put curfew in place and
they arrested a hundred and fifty people
oh my god
oh my god what are those they feel like
split as [ __ ] that was a firework
right it's like project x oh damn
oh oh
a [ __ ] bunch of horses no they
started using rubber bullets they
started using i think paint balls that's
fine
the paintball pepper spray yeah yeah
this party got out of hand so wait is
this
is this a is this a viral tick tock
person like no this guy was a regular
teenager in huntington beach and the
tick tock that he posted went viral
people just ran into some [ __ ] to do
yeah oh god oh no he had enough drinks
somebody is somebody was
oh no oh oh oh that's messed up oh he's
laughing we're doing it
a bunch of people were doing it it was
like a party game it's a thing yeah yeah
i don't really get it but people are
doing it actively whoa
oh they're falling this just gives me so
much anxiety oh dude me too nightmare i
couldn't believe it
right yeah nothing could happen i'm so
[ __ ] out of there i i can't get out of
those places i could not do it
looks like i had a girlfriend who used
to take she would see a crowd like that
and just be like she was so hot and
she'd just be like we're going there i'd
be like i guess okay and i'd just be a
nervous wreck wow
it's stressful because [ __ ] is litty
like a titty
now what's going on here all right
it does people like the mod they like
the meat mash they like the meatball
so that's that's all younger what'd you
say
right oh yeah well yeah you're big
enough right so you can just get in
there
you'll still monster
someone follows you pick them up like
everyone's trying to protect each other
yeah but you guys running yeah i'm a
kind person you're a good person and
i've also never fallen in a pit so
i've been to some of the businesses
football buddies yeah you football
players got in there we just saw kids
getting
[ __ ] concussed you're not supposed to
do that a middle linebacker sean tufts
kathleen the team went to a mouse party
linebacker is the
the guy that stops the running back
usually hold on
he doesn't have football you don't watch
football at all no you don't know what
it's like i know how to cheer it on i
tell you that much and then i'll show
you 15
you don't go no i don't know these
positions you know it's quarterback
i know the quarterback i know the
running back the corner back but there's
so many people on that front line that
i'm like i don't know
if you've never seen it you're a unique
dude man yeah thank you i appreciate it
you're very unique i know people think
it's crazy because people came up to me
on the show they're like yo do you
really not know
a lot of stuff and i go you got to
realize my everyday life
i'm just journaling reading playing
guitar
or something with comedy yeah so like
most of the time i'm not like
that's it i'm not watching the movies
like like i just got a tv more so
recently i haven't had a tv since
2011. well i stopped going down the
rabbit hole on news and stuff you know
yeah i just
even philosophy because like there's
always a counterpoint
and you're never going to really change
anybody's mind by mounting your point of
view
like it's hard to do it's like you watch
this and you're like ah [ __ ] man
yeah it's like you said like you could
present people with evidence like god
could be there and be like
yeah i know but how can i be sure that
you're god this goes a lot higher than a
week yeah
exactly that's how i feel yeah that's
what's frustrating what else she got
okay chappelle this is for you because i
don't know what this actually means
but simone biles nails a
gymnastics move that apparently nobody
has done because it's so dangerous right
yeah and this is just can you explain it
to us she's a [ __ ] monster
that's what she is like like what's the
significance of this
watch you'll see it
like it looks insane why is it so hot
i think based off of what she's doing it
off of um
is it's just no one can do it off that
yeah
and i guess it's really dangerous yeah
it's just i mean
she's just she's such a beast huh she's
insane she's like the michael jordan of
gymnastics yeah
she's so fast she's she's like let me
ask you this why
do all gymnastic girls run like this
it's the form do they force them around
if you run no no no because if you run
like crazy it doesn't
it kind of breaks your form whereas this
like keeps you just playing them out
yeah it's four because like when you're
when you press off like you want
you want that straight look at me
[ __ ] explaining this [ __ ]
i get to explain a linebacker oh yeah
true
damn dog everyone here knows what i'm
like i mean cat was like i don't want a
middle linebacker
i'm all bougie about explaining let me
explain why they're
but nobody's making a big deal about
this no they are it's all they are yeah
it's all over it doesn't seem like
anybody
no literally it's all over b yeah just
yeah no i mean she
there was one skill she did i can't
remember which one it was lebron's
thursday
my god they basically had to uh take it
out of the
they made it illegal yeah it's illegal
because [ __ ] were like in their names
they were like no one else is going to
be able to do that
but they did that in ice skating too
right i don't know there was a
like a black olympian who did a move
that they end up banning because they
said it was too dangerous but she was
only one who could land it really yeah i
didn't know about that
only thing i know about ice skating is
the home girl that got her knee busted
that's pretty nice that's what yeah is
that who it is tell your heart here one
two three
boom yeah it's insane crazy huh yeah
and she's just so like now she's gonna
come she's so quick and just
what is she gonna compete in the
olympics or she yeah yeah absolutely i
think she's uh
23. yeah she's young she's super she
looks like
they're like but that's dog years in
gymnastics right twenty years because
they started i think when
you started eating at like 12 yeah they
start real early
and then like you actually compete
compete at 16. but she's tiny
because totally tumbling like stunts
you're gross you ever tumbled
yeah that's yeah that's my [ __ ] oh okay
yeah like those videos and stuff like
the back the back tuck that's tumbling
don't worry yeah yeah
yeah but i never i didn't i didn't do
gymnastics you know
i learned in the backyard just because i
was a geek of martial art films and i
just went outside which i started doing
it yourself
i started doing it yeah that's how i
learned it was i was like five years old
wow i was watching those old uh shaolin
sophia
oh yeah yeah gymnastics god i [ __ ]
with tiger i was telling chappelle this
so he's
i came home yesterday from the airport
he's like dad you want me to make you a
bracelet i made mom and grandma bracelet
i'm like yeah dude make do it up
and then he makes it it's all pink and
white oh come on dude you're making uh
girly [ __ ] man i go mix it up there can
we get a little the red little the black
he's like oh okay okay and then i leave
i would go to the bathroom
i guess his mom was like i thought you
made uh dad a bracelet already
goes i did mom but i'm making girly [ __ ]
she's like you gotta quit cussing foot
tiger i was like oh whoops
what's wrong with pink though uh it was
just like yellow pink like i can't you
know it was very pastel yeah it's very
easter before yeah yes
speaking of girlies
so uh a-rod has come out with his own
line of makeup and the internet's kind
of split on this
yeah because some people are like oh
yeah cool guys wearing makeup who cares
and other people are like why the [ __ ]
is that rod making makeup
like why does he have a makeup line he's
been tv so long he decided to launch his
own makeup line
i guess i think he's sealer though i can
tell her yeah what's concealer
concealer is basically uh like a more
pigmented foundation to cover up your
dark spots
to make everything just even so if you
can't cover up this dark spot
there is makeup for you now it's like
pimples and stuff like that
we can find a savage ex fenty i just
don't get why
they look for you guys i think it's
because jlo recently
released her skincare and they probably
started it together when they were still
i thought they weren't together though
they're not anymore
peter gabriel oh you know oh
yeah i can see
the city lights yes every white person
peter gabriel you know like he's my
generation literally
how about we met him how about we met
his exact doppelganger
like this black girl same color sim same
everything
piercing blue eyes coming into the green
room with the mask on she goes
what's up dudes all right man we're
gonna have a fun show tonight hope you
guys catch a vibe
i'll see you out there all right and
then uh i think it was all coming up the
nipsy hustle she's like not familiar
with nipsy hustle
you sure you want to come out some
rancid or something we're like no we're
good
she was just like him just like me wow
just just as dark as she comes
she comes in when he goes on stage comes
he goes hey do you have a charger by any
chance
the controller for my video game is
running low bro i could use you can
charge you to play some video games i'm
like
no i don't know no problem dude
no problem dude but she was like dark as
him but it was like
you would not expect it give it up for
your first comic justin
elliot this crowd is rocking tonight
wow blue eyes yeah or were they green or
they were
cool yeah it was funny so funny i was
like
she walked out i was like is that me you
know that spiderman meme where they're
both playing each other i was like
chappelle is that your sister all right
everybody we have a rocking show tonight
see you guys out there we're
that's great she was the best she was so
great yeah she was great
well okay wait wait let's go back to
concealer yeah
my over under is that gonna sell i don't
know i don't think anybody's buying it
or anybody's buying stevie does yeah
every now and then if he has like a
little
like oh like a zit or something to cover
it up i guess oh that's what it does
yeah oh okay i was thinking it was like
full on like
no you don't you can spot use it it's
spot yeah if i'm on
tv you can use it for like under your
dark eyes like right now
oh okay yeah yeah i guess that wait can
you use it i got it for pimples yeah
yeah i'll do a little dab of [ __ ] all
right
um yeah okay well i don't know about
full makeup though no no
you start wearing mascara bro yeah yeah
pimples i'll cover pimples yeah
you know what you give out a bad
breakout
buy concealer as a man i don't know
i like i don't see that making lots of
money they said there's many times
people be surprised how many guys use it
for like blemishes yeah
like if i had that [ __ ] in high school
when i might i had [ __ ] pizza face
sign me up yeah yeah yeah it would have
really helped me out i think dudes are
lazy
but i mean yeah would you say guys are
lazy though with that [ __ ]
you'd be surprised yeah how many guys
are in the fashion like the sneaker
heads
yeah for sure the sneaker hasn't wearing
makeup that's what's different about it
i'm just saying guys are in the fashion
oh yeah a lot of guys are into fashion
younger kids are
really into like painting their nails
and doing their makeup guys yeah
like androgynous kind of like bts look
isn't it i've seen that a lot
mm-hmm but like you the one that you're
breaking like you always dressed pretty
well no
sir you read the room wrong i read the
room wrong he is
the furthest thing from but i'm just i
just he's older i think i i know i'm
bombed on that sentence
i don't know i just don't know how to
you know like i i
if it fits the same uniforms for seven
years
yes he's like batman
i do it was the same colored shirts and
blazers and he's like a cartoon
if you if you dress up you just put a
blazer over that that's what you do i
bought expensive blazers yeah and caught
like
i've spent money and they're on my
hanger and the dust
has settled into i think if you wear
collared sure to just make you look
older
i just became around the college surely
every time i started doing that and
rogan would be like well you look like a
[ __ ]
librarian or a teacher look at a
salesman yeah look like a history
teacher when you dress
up yeah yeah oh you're like but you
don't look
bad i'm trying to look at what i'm
saying i look like a [ __ ]
like a i teach uh social studies you're
italian in
irish irish yeah what else you got jen
um that christian you use concealer you
punch in the [ __ ] nose what happened
yeah what's the story there did i get
some concealer on it or what dude
uh i had a rough weekend why um it
better be better than the story told
earlier
it will be um so like leading up to the
weekend uh
i broke my tv box and i fell off my tv
sand
someone dented my car with a shopping
cart or a door
and then uh me and my oldest brother
were getting into an altercation and i
had a cookie sheet
right why were you getting you and your
brother were fighting yeah brother
yeah butterflies yeah no like him and i
are cool now
my brother got a straight up argument
o.j simpson he was saying he's innocent
i was the creator of your [ __ ] mind
we didn't talk to each other for three
hours what was this
over the window barbecue i was like
you're out of your [ __ ] mind he's
like no i'm not i've seen you guys like
you're [ __ ] out of your i see you
guys
you get into each other's faces and he
does not back down he's just older
brother oh yeah man he [ __ ] and he'll
he'll he's got he's got fortified
arguments
on this one i think he's probably wrong
but i was like your [ __ ]
and he was like oh i read this way i've
read i read that book in four more
that's all i read dude
i'm like what do you want let's go
through the steps i go through the steps
with him i'm like you're out of your
mind did he continue he's like oh you
can be the only one who's right i'm like
of course i'm right this is a in dude
and then we started arguing and then we
just didn't talk to each other yeah
and then the beans got spilled on his
brain he you know he loves f1 driving he
got this exclusive lewis hamilton
tom tommy hilfiger collection it was
like a 300 jersey he puts on he's like
dope is this something that's cool man
we're at truth barbecue the guy's like
hey i got some
uh he's bringing this song
dude all over his right jersey i don't
mean like
a splash the entire set of beans went
all over his white shirt
and j you know jay he goes oh oh man man
and then i guess i'll go get a towel and
jay goes
i'm really [ __ ] mad right because he
said he waited like three months for
that shirt
he goes i hope it doesn't stain oh yeah
and then the guy leaves it jay looks
good because i'm really [ __ ] mad
right now
and then jay went to the bathroom the
only worst and i looked at everyone with
jay's pits yeah
baked beans the only worst might be
blood like that would be like
i got a cup of butter but the guy was
selling that he you know they're
bringing us everything that truth
barbecue and these yeah these baked
beans
the one guy in all white i'm not like
not a spot
the entire like a [ __ ] family-sized
surfing of baked beans all over his back
come on
and they were hot [ __ ] hell burn yeah
that'll [ __ ] we all started laughing
yeah
jacob's james got quiet he got real
quiet
went to the bathroom he came back he's
like that better have fun yeah because
they gave him like a truth shirt to
switch out on but they got he got it out
yeah it's out it's crazy the dude like
immediately they like soaked it or
whatever
oh it did all right so the uh shirts
okay who's the guy
out of all the people like i'd rather
anything almost anything else spill on
me
baked beans i just started lying don't
go dude big beans that's easy you know
just trying to make it because you're a
stainless yeah yeah that doesn't seem in
the fibers
we're just gonna get some
but i can't but i can't i will figure it
out i know a guy who needs heart surgery
uh friend of the family and and it was
funny because
i go oh okay it sounds better yeah but
he's got the best surgeon
and i go that doesn't matter no i was
like what does that mean
and there he's the best there you go at
what
what do you mean he's the best you can
be the best at heart surgery yeah i know
but how do you measure that how do you
measure that well how many how many
successful times he's done it well you
know what i did i
expected i guess but you don't have a
record of that
and then i i youtubed heart surgery the
kind of heart surgery he needs
yeah and in the [ __ ] surgery the dude
ends up working on the left perineum
instead of the right his actual doctor
no but there's a doctor but
when you open it up like that you open
up the [ __ ] heart and you see that
much
right i know i'm gonna get [ __ ] for
surgeons but i went down the rabbit hole
yeah
but you went down to youtube you know
what the conspiracy theorists do no i
went oh you found something dude
this guy knows what he's doing i looked
at [ __ ] but he's a pro
yeah but here's the thing why did you
question it there's this there's this
nerve that you can that you want to make
sure you don't hit otherwise you don't
think he knows that
no i'm saying sometimes people by like
sometimes people
doctors go and they they catch it now he
got some problems
yeah how often does he miss that nerve
how often does he hit it i'm saying you
don't have [ __ ] metrics
for knowing if a guy's yeah if that's
good
for that that means like i think don't
you think you would inspire
if you if i look it up and he has like
that like his ex like he's a experienced
doctor this is what i do and then brian
comes along
listen bro i youtubed it there's this
thing i'm like yeah shut up i'm saying
i'm saying here's what you want with a
surgeon i think here's my number one
thing what's your number one thing
experience and what does that mean i'm
looking for gray hair
i'm not looking for a baby face no no i
don't want a young like
harvard doctor fresh out can't wait i
don't know you know
my favorite like like the guy who
delivered my
my girls uh uh our babies he's
i i was like he's gonna die he's 85 and
she's like yeah but he's delivered over
three thousand babies that's what i want
so like any complication he's been in it
i want something is this guy a young
heart surgeon is that why you didn't
believe him about him i just know the
guy
he just went down youtube and then
started talking about the [ __ ] that
was like what are you the worst friend
ever i was like i was like be specific
about what do you mean by the best
though
what me how is he the best if he's 90
he's done it a lot
yeah and he hasn't been sued but there's
some there's some doctors that have
track records of doing that surgery
they have traction and they're
successful do they keep wha who keeps
the metrics on that
what if the guy if you go up to me like
how long have you done this he's like
i've done
your exact surgery 50. so the reason i
say this there's a famous [ __ ] spine
surgeon
that i know that i know of this is the
exception though
the spine surgeon makes money gets
kickbacks for putting screws in your
[ __ ] back
the hospital makes money too so they
recommend that guy so the guy
the i was there one of the surgeons came
and i was there when the surgeon came
when the
patient came in the guy had major pain
and the guy goes
yeah because they go to this [ __ ]
surgeon and i always get his runoff
and he didn't say you know then i found
out his name but
just because the guy's popular doesn't
mean he's the best he might be making
money
doing [ __ ] that isn't as good and you
get away with that for a long time
because most doctors are going to be
around for a long time if they're
[ __ ] up surgeries
yeah you hang out with triplet too much
i don't know about that
yeah you get away with it for a long
time
what about the guy that did these the
best the best the [ __ ]
what makes her the best what makes him
the best
why don't you youtube kardashians
i like them right away and and yeah but
you don't know what [ __ ] about the guy
older yeah yeah and he's doing it a
thousand times
and did he want to do more no i said no
i i go because he
he wanted to do more no he didn't he in
fact he goes he goes very
straightforward you're just gonna he
goes i'm not going to do a lot you're
going to look like you're a little less
tired that's it
i love that i was like all right dude
and i woke up and i look at how good now
here's the thing
you look exactly the same it's because
i like how you go to this guy he's a
kardashian's doctor that's good
i do hear that with the doctors that the
kardashians work with they get
so big so quickly and so many people
want to go to them looking like the
kardashians that it's almost like a chop
shop for plastic surgery
you're not actually getting the doctor
that the kardashians are
working with you
because there are 150 000 to work yeah
exactly so most people like i can't
afford that like yeah
well he doesn't do it but this guy can
for 20. yeah but i'd argue that jason
diamond got there
got to where he is because and got a lot
more clients than that
because he you see results he's [ __ ]
awesome he looks great he's a great guy
he was on he was he's a celebrity
classic surgeon oh he is yeah he's a
[ __ ]
that's who did your lid yeah but he's
he's a dude yeah he [ __ ] loves mma
he's a great guy oh let's
hey let's take it easy because uh yeah
so you can't go bad on the heart surge
and then this guy who had a reality show
don't take [ __ ] about him in the arts
bro take your [ __ ] hey hey take your
next surgery
now did he have a reality show and try
to get famous yeah he did is that the
guy you want doing your surgery i didn't
no hey why not he's a bad [ __ ]
he knows what he's doing
trust me he's a guy's guy man oh okay he
wants to go to him hey
i'm gonna go to wow take back what
you're saying dude hey you know what
else i love
is you didn't do any research your girl
did your girl did
all right maybe and then you went yeah
i'm not you have no clue i'm lazy i'm
lazy with that i'm not
you know i've technically had i've had
technically had
two plastic surgeries on my on my face
where else
my hair transplant oh the hair didn't
really work neither worked though did it
didn't work
this worked you dude you look exactly
like i ate
i ate salt yesterday i'm swollen you
always say that i know but i do
everything you did have nuts hanging off
your eyelids though i know
i know when you see pictures it's
there's a difference no you look excited
and i don't give a [ __ ] you look
identical
how crazy is that what do you wake up
what a waste of time
what a waste of money
i can see so much better i don't know
what you guys are talking about
what else you got look at my eyes look
what happened to my face in general
[ __ ] all right we'll get off of this one
that's [ __ ] hilarious okay this is a
quick one
but a twitter account called uber fax
wrote something along the lines of
what's the most
uh high risk low reward job you've ever
done and monica lewinsky
replied oh that's so funny and it went
viral good for her
what did she say yeah oh that's what she
did
good for her that's i think she has her
uh movie coming out soon
or it's in production now it's about
about her and that incident
there's a whole movie about that yeah
so there's that just a quick one cool
going around the studio right now that
was a bee i have that uh i have that
salt gun i i want flies i look for
flowers
what is that it's the bug assault the
bug assault you're seen the commercials
that i don't know my neighbor invented
the gun game i don't have a dude i just
started watching i have one i have one
with a sight [ __ ] bug assault bro i
have one with a sight
i have a legend yeah bring up what you
can do
i slaughter i slaughter flies all day
long
four years ago hang on oh dude i [ __ ]
killed him yeah he's already yeah
oh rambo there's no hi
my name is lorenzo and i'm the is that
your neighbor yeah he invented it
flies are disgusting i've never had a
fly bro
ever thanks a lot tony
this commercial text your food and your
health with
the bug of salt simple to use just pour
ordinary table salt
[ __ ] aim remove safety and fire
non-toxic air powered
no batteries required now watch this
that's what happened now you have dead
flies all day
but now there's salt everywhere and dead
flies yeah did you get to kill me
look at that oh well why don't you just
take a newspaper and hit him
because you can't dude if you hit that
homeboy is really trying to sell this
gun
bro it's the best go to bugasalt.com
but my kids my kids don't like me
killing the [ __ ] bugs so it flies so
that they they hide the [ __ ] my guns
i have ten of them and they're all over
the house
are you the only person keeping your
friend in business yes no no
no he's making a fortune on this
actually a lot of people use
i've never heard of them yeah yeah
they're they're making they're making a
force i've never heard of a bug assault
but it sounds dope oh
he sells them online they're [ __ ] i
don't know anyone who's like ma'am so
[ __ ] sick these flies
you don't live but we don't live in that
area dude there's a room
around here we don't have an area oh you
know what i do i keep my door shut you
don't live on the east coast dude yeah i
don't like you making fun of bugatti
my plastic surgeon [ __ ] dude
what a shitty idea
no dude it's right shut the door it's
made of food yeah what are we going to
do
it's watch how much it's made yeah well
based off that commercial
no it's made up that's so funny actually
finally 27 million in 2018.
hold on the company says revenues was 27
million no
it's we're gonna believe that bug guy i
don't believe that look at their shopify
account and he's got 10 of them
yeah cnbc yeah yeah it actually made a
lot of money yeah yeah
i can imagine yeah yeah that makes sense
it would be great right now
yeah it would be to get this thing yeah
what the what salt [ __ ] up flies or
something like you aim it and the salt
well can it be can i put sugar in there
yeah it could be anything [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna shoot sugar and stuff you can give
them sugar flies
sugar's too powdery everywhere yeah
salt salt nothing nothing grows on salt
you understand yes
so that's what happens that's what you
saw after my after my first two loves
broke up with me
then they they poured salt on my heart
and nuts
guy
what every guy thinks when one girl just
like that
at that age was like listen good i'm
like bubba listen to me cat's very nice
when you do something with your hair i
gotta do something we gotta do we gotta
we have to just leave you you don't go
like a barber or anything
i do what i do but it's just they could
style that i'm losing no there's no way
you're there what do you mean there's
hair on his head right now it's just in
certain spots there's no hair yeah
you're gonna see every [ __ ] detail no
i'm not looking at it like that i'm
looking because there's hair on your
head yeah i'm with your mom
get a wig i'm not getting no you don't
need to get a wig no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no look
they do you wanna try that one out we
have one they just haven't
just like a tester they haven't uh they
haven't
have they can't clone the hair anymore i
know the guy who does the hair in l.a
she's going to wait it out but you got
it yeah but then yeah i got to do a hair
transplant which means i got to take
hair
more hair they're still doing that but
this is [ __ ] hair i don't have good
hair
does that really work for some people
now can they take care from like me and
put it on you
no if they took mine i'd love it
they could take yours i was [ __ ] pain
he said i'd love it
sorry man i'd love to have thick hair
like that yeah you're going to be gray
in about
five years and that's fine i'm going
gray yeah yeah yeah yeah you got a
little gray little gray beard yeah what
else you got jen
your mustache any grays no i do i just
started
like sprouting them like oh do you die a
year ago
i'll pluck it out you're 44. it took 44
yeah you think about getting married
still dating your girl
i'm still dating my girl no marriage i
don't know dude he can't commit to a bug
gun
i feel like he'll look good he'd be a
good dad she doesn't want to have kids i
don't know if i want to have kids either
okay she doesn't
no damn yeah all right how old is she 30
she's turning 38 in september all right
your mom and dad say that i don't it
drives me [ __ ] crazy i know my
parents
really want grandkids how they do yeah
what are you laughing about
does your brother have kids what's going
on brendan said something like oh i go
i go hide my casual i might really don't
have kisses because i don't drives me
[ __ ] crazy
someone say you're doing your part for
not to not like yeah this overpopulates
the world is getting crazy
there are a lot of parts i love that
that's my favorite the people
the world's getting crazy oh is it is it
that crazy crazy
is it crazy you're driving from your
[ __ ] sweet penthouse mandel ray to
here is it
yeah we're supposed to go camping that
never happened i'd love to go camping
i cannot imagine you're going to get me
right i really can't i'm actually he's a
camper
is he really no oh yeah i highly doubt
brian would go no but i
would come you don't do anything
outdoorsy yeah i hunt dude
oh yeah you do yeah that's a lose story
we haven't been hunting a while oh god
yeah you know it's gonna say that's a
lot don't miss it so you say you used to
hunt
yeah there is something about going out
in the wilderness that that's i'd be
down to do it like yeah i'd be done
if you start going out in the wilderness
for real if you start like going out
yeah you'll get addicted to it am i
tripping or did i see you with some dope
photos of you with some
lions or something like that what that's
right i did with a cheetah i was in a
chicken
south africa and i did it with a chicken
well that's outdoorsy isn't it
yeah yeah not really that's just like a
throwback
people cooking food for me are you
already covered i told you i told you
about safaris right like for me you're
talking about it
when you go to salary we've been doing
the show for seven years
yeah he's like you do stand-up bee tell
me about it man how long have you been
in san diego
safaris are all it's just it's so
saturated yeah and
most of them are ranches that you're
going those real ones
yeah but those are dangerous aren't they
i mean
you can sleep oh i saw that movie you're
ranting raving about with uh i watched
on the play
unhinged on hints you watched it it's so
intense how crazy is that
so that's the russell crowe thing yeah
300 pounds
yeah it's the movie's so intense
it's it's good it's like it's only
showing on planes though
it's so good i saw it on the plane too
he's a great actor how about that
opening scene i was like oh
yeah yeah you're like what the [ __ ] he's
a great doctor my favorite part of the
movie is when he
spoiler in three two one it's already
out is when he uh
you know he fights when he gets her
phone yeah she's supposed to meet with
her lawyer
the lawyer he sits down at that right
there he sits down with a lawyer yeah
he's like you're kind of guy that [ __ ]
me over with my wife he's like wait what
and then he [ __ ] that dude up yes bad
movie's so intense my anxiety in that
scene was going like out
my anxiety was going through the roof i
can't believe you liked it the whole
thing
i don't like mine is that who's the guy
next to him there what's
is that really his belly or is that a
fat suit this guy next to him yeah who's
that guy
what do you look like when he was when
he did gladiator was he all there's a
side by side but again that's like
a director maybe wait what so so um what
is
doesn't matter but what is is that
really how heavy he got for that part
yeah look at him holy [ __ ] he likes to
he likes to booze i know he likes
he's so good in this man oh and he
smokes too damn
his accent he's a pretty good southern
accent yeah
the movie's really i feel like that's a
fat suit i really do i don't think he's
that heavy i know he put on weight
yeah i think that's look at his face
that's really him how big his face is
people don't wait for it yeah that's a
real belly oh when he pulls up
we get him there look at him doing the
posting in the glasses chin with the
gray hair
look at him jesus yeah he put on a lot
of weight for this yeah
well he he's he was very heavy to begin
with like he was he
yeah his face is like mine i feel like
he's always been like kind of
slimmer in movies no no you're thinking
of gladiator but
uh when he was an american gangster he
wasn't fat that was right around class
how'd this movie when a gladiator come
out no
look at his face wow jim when was
gladiator
15 years ago 20. in 2008 american
gangster was 2000.
gladiators 2008 though yeah gladiator
was 2 000.
21 years ago literally and then when was
american gangs was 2007
i want to say so seven years i'm saying
earlier i'm saying american gangster was
even earlier
what was it watch i think so 2007.
you know what i saw that i thought was
so good
yeah 2006. that's a really good movie
damn it i know someone yeah on hinges
it's it's so intense
would you scale 110 when you get it uh
nine oh that good
it's [ __ ] good oh it's that good yeah
it's really good and i wanna see what
about the sound of metal did you see
this
yeah that's good nine really good i'm
giving out nine i know you're
gonna have nice you're getting out of
nines bro let me let me can we good
i'm talking about one to ten can you can
you be a little bit more i mean of all
movies
nine we haven't been theaters what's a
ten what's an eight
i don't know they're good they're
they're worth your time you you
like like that gin movie actually about
a scary movie that's for what it is it's
like
that's a eight or nine they're good and
then what about nomad land do you see
that i didn't see that i didn't
have no desire no what else you got to
do
uh you know i actually went to the
movies to the actual theater recently
and saw that in l.a yeah marina where
matt's the whole time no
it's that place where you sit down they
give you orders
dangerous you have to wear a mask no
marine is six i think it's kind of
six yeah it's amazing what movie did you
say uh nobody
that's a good movie oh yeah and i'm
still gonna watch that everyone keeps
writing about it
what's that guy from um breaking bad i
think i heard that guy used to be a
comic book
bob odenkirk yeah odin mr show he
created mr show he's [ __ ] he's
really good i've worked with bob he's a
great question did he do stand up
uh he started he was a sketch guy big
time skating sketch guys
okay call mr show got it and he's moving
he's good what's it about if you like it
if you like
john wick kind of movies it's like that
it's funny as i can actually
yeah oh no i'm out like oh no it's good
though it's really good
why are you out bob is a regular like
john wick it's great i don't like john
wick
you don't like john wick no oh my god
you're one of the very few
i like i've seen john wick it's good i
want to go to i wouldn't like to for me
to go to theater i'd get a babysitter
also i'm going to see john wake for
you you're not going to theater for john
wick a guy who's on a revenge tour for
his dog i'm not watching
this is actually funny too though it's a
good story yeah i think you'll like it
it's it is yeah it's a good story well
you said the same thing about unhinged i
watched you i was talking you were
talking [ __ ] about it
though true hbo max is nice because it
has like all
again i prefer movies to come out at
home yeah it has if you have kids that's
the way to do it yeah
i'm going to watch unhinged that's good
i'm going to watch it it's so intense
girl in it's so frustrating like just
drive to the station don't you
and when she takes a kid out of school
i'm like you [ __ ] idiot well also
don't like i never give people the
finger unless i'm willing to get out and
fight
that woman i guess gave that that poor
kid was killed over the weekend
six-year-old
shot in the back road rage and uh
because she gave the guy the finger
and uh oh my god mad at the finger
the
i always assume people are going to do
[ __ ] like always
so i'm not fighting in a car i'm not no
i'm not going to be like [ __ ] you you
cut me off i
never know what people are going through
either someone cuts me off i'm like or
whatever
which is basically unhinged yeah it's so
intense you don't know but he takes it
to the next
there's there's no movie if she just
apologized in the beginning where he
goes
he is so she like he's waiting there to
go and she's
he's trying to be cool and and she goes
beep beep like really hard and he pulls
up he goes
he's talking the kid he goes now let's
get i i i i assume you want you want to
do a courtesy hunk just a beep beep
like that to let me know i should have
went and she goes yeah whatever he is
well hold on it's not whatever and he's
like going through some [ __ ] just yeah
he was it's not whatever if he can just
apologize and say i should have done the
courtesy hunk
then i can move on with my day she was
like whatever [ __ ] off he's like
oh yes well no it's not [ __ ] off and
then it's all it's
it's similar all i'm asking for is a
little curtis
that's all that's all he said he goes
you can just solve the courtesy huh
that's all she goes whatever [ __ ] off
he's like
it's not [ __ ] off and then he's like
you're gonna pay for it no movie if i'm
on the wheel me i'm like i'm sorry
brother i'm really sorry
this movie is so intense yesterday my
buddy fabricio owns
owens uh yeah we're driving in
in just a little prius he rolls right
through a stop sign
it's late no big deal he goes ah we're
gonna get pulled over hundred percent
like what he goes
100 cop pulls up flashlight
goes you saw you saw that stop sign
right shots outside because
just it's a woman we don't know it's
driving you saw a stop sign you roll
right through it
and i go i saw it and yes he did
oh you're a stitch oh snatch i guess
well that clock damn right yeah but i
can turn it into the passage
tell they're not gonna give us tickets
why because he's pulled up right here in
the middle of the road he's just giving
us these
and she says very nicely she says please
do me a favor and come to a full stop
appreciate it and i go we will and and
let's go it goes fabricio goes
well i thought i did stop oh no
as they're taking off carl just goes
stop so short that she went like that
she went
like that and then i and then uh back
up and i go i and and i go no we did
roll through
we did roll through and the cop the guy
goes that's a smart
answer that's a smart answer yes sir
how do you think that's an eagle he just
got out no he did he didn't
i did i did i did it [ __ ] man
come on dude you're you're out you're
out i got pulled over in the porsche and
the cops like
you know how fast you were going man i'm
like i don't know i don't know dude
and i go here's this thing i cannot
drive fast he starts laughing and i get
it
yeah it's great i've done that yeah i
did the best as i did one time i just
decided to be a smart
ass he goes you were you know how fast
you were going i go i know
you know sometimes officer i saw the
road she was empty
and i had to take her he started
laughing
so hard the thing about their day yeah
so much fun i do that and then another
time i pull i [ __ ] go
from here i pull all the way through
yeah
cop caller is why should i not give you
the ticket of your life i go worth it
it's worth it and he goes what do you
mean i go worth it he goes
what are you saying i go well i gotta go
pick my girlfriend up and that's a
flower shop
and i'd rather get the ticket of my life
than show up without flowers
yeah i'll start laughing but hey guys
tell my partner what you just said
i have my license registration let's
just stick out the door when they walk
over here
and i know i was going too fast man it's
just you just make it easy on me yeah i
never why are you guys speeding they
always say you're not going to talk me
out of a ticket you can talk yourself
into a ticket though yeah
because you know their their job they
deal with negativity
all people are such and especially now
like cops just deal with [ __ ] all day
it's like [ __ ] man it's a hard job
yeah right it's you're just dealing with
negative you first of all your job is to
give people
people to show me yeah i'm never that
way no never
[ __ ] what else you got chin have you
guys ever seen a
uh gaboon viper crawl yes oh yeah i've
seen uh crawlers probably
what do you mean i'll show you right now
hold on for a second oh this thing's
about
[ __ ] couple things about the gaboon
fire they have the longest bang
of all [ __ ] serpents how long brandon
long get up to two inches long really
two now that's a two inches
yeah go ahead brandon sean now now
okay now i told that you got me
told the story before a kid broke into
the white the dc zoo
tell them what that viper did doug i'll
tell you look at that right there oh my
god
that's not two inches but let's keep
going that's in the congo brother now
hold on that's not two inches but let's
pretend it is that's that's easily two
inches that's an inch now hold on that's
two inches now listen up
uh he put those [ __ ] in a uh he put
those [ __ ] in a in a burlap sack
threw him over his bag got on the bus
those guy boons went tell them about the
sack
tell them about the sound i don't like
it you've seen the sack yeah now now you
see those fangs
burlap sack that's again not two inches
but we're gonna pretend they're two
inches okay two inches
keep going that's two that's another
answer
and the thing went you know what your
burlap sack is no good here gonna bite
through guess what we can get through
this burlap sap on your back beat him on
him enjoy this
spit him on the back think about it that
was a kid
demons is double teenager
this is double fat and that and that's
some yellow venom that's some yellow
i think that's a hemotoxin and i think
it's a neurotoxin and you know what else
dehydrated oh yeah you ever think about
that yeah so it [ __ ] up with you [ __ ]
with your nervous system and i think
your blood
and and now now he got so he's paralyzed
forever but anyway
he's paralyzed forever correct sir
you're not walking again and he got off
lucky because usually
you die now let me see this thing crawl
cause you look at that
viper by the way look at how long the
goddamn a little rattlesnake i'm [ __ ]
with the mountains
top there look at that look at that puff
powder well that's about to be sharp
[ __ ] facts
that is [ __ ] crazy yeah bro but look
how it crawls it's such a trip let me
see
that's how i crossed forward they can do
the side thing too but that's how it
crawls forward
now uh that's a regular snake slithering
forward it's slippery no
no i don't know it's not really cruel to
me is like this
if it will if it has hands and feet see
i thought you were saying that hands and
feet that's a snake
is that it right there that's it watch
you'll see it start crawling
yeah like a slithering
though it does look like it's crawling
yeah but it's you know what that is
that's a snake slithering up a mountain
but let's
need you to use the correct definition
watch it here watch it
watch it again yeah that is it's that
short fat snake slithering up the mouth
then he goes to slither
then he does it side by side that's what
he gets for [ __ ] having eve bite the
apple
and adam and ruining the snakes are
[ __ ] scary because god said
you will crawl on your belly for the
rest of time that is [ __ ] crazy
they're so scary now you don't want a
kaboom
and they're out of africa they are from
they are from
oh i believe i believe that they're why
do they let this thing in the [ __ ]
house
i think it's a pet shop or something
like that see look how it does the crawl
do you know how dangerous that is i see
right i see where there's so much
slither
caterpillar yeah yeah you're not an
aggressive snake apparently
look at this little bottom mirror but
don't see though see those glands see
how that diamond this
is what you mean it's so pretty yeah
it's like that's venom
in in in his cheeks yeah they're cool on
the cheeks they have giant heads
over there yeah because they're they're
they're they're filled with that feeling
well that thing belongs in
in the on the jungle dude
gabon where is gabon in africa i believe
it's in the right it's in central
everything looks pretty slow there
no that's gaboon yeah is it the pit
viper that hangs out in the trees get
you in the eyes
chin or uh west africa looks like west
yeah next to cameroon
i'm sorry it's very west hey b what's
what's the one that hangs out in the
trees you gotta watch is that the
that's that would be that would be the
um
that would be the best you know about
this hangs out in trees
that's an eyelash viper i believe
eyelash viper is what i'm looking for
for
hours now now that that's in that's in
costa rica so if you're a costa rica
please be in there yep be aware look at
the trees
brown tree snake well no the brown ones
safe no i'm talking about the [ __ ]
thing that hangs out the trees then
[ __ ] eat your eyeballs yeah i think
it's i like fish
big snake death kiss because it's not
huge but it's going to hit you right in
the [ __ ] eyes well you can just put
eyelash vibrate if you want
eyelash yeah type an eyelash viper there
there it is
and they're gonna be yellow so oh my
gosh
they look cool as well now that's
there's a color and there's two mating
on top there now yeah
see that is right gorgeous chapelle
that's what's beautiful like it's
gorgeous whatever it is
there it is now it's gonna come straight
for your eyeball now are they big no no
they look small they're small so you're
like oh look at that little caterpillar
wrong
ah wrong it looks like
yellow dragon it looks like a dragon and
it's a tiny dragon and
it will [ __ ] kill you dragon and it
bites you in your face
in your unsuspecting face that's gonna
bite me i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna kill him i'm gonna i'm gonna
rep yeah but is that one pretty venomous
oh yeah yeah death in the face which one
is that again you're not getting help
quick and you're gonna have operations
and that that poison
[ __ ] with you you go blind it's bad
news man don't get bit
in the face yeah she got jenna i gotta
roll yeah pick tiger up um
i think we could we gonna do that i'll
just do another instagram one then
oh wait not that one this one this one i
thought was funny
he's trying to smoke pot underneath his
shirt because it's like in a public
place
okay okay
keep watching oh [ __ ]
he catches on fire god
oh he's still smoking he's trying to go
undercover but
gangster and there you go yeah he's not
that was it
for weeks even when he's on fire he's
cool he's like
let me see if i can blow it out that's
it
all right that's it that's it all right
uh chappelle
lacey and david lucas oklahoma city
oklahoma brickstown comic club
june 10th through the 12th and then
we'll have more dates but the only other
one on there is denver colorado
comedy works downtown denver september
30th my mom
coming home mama i'm
coming home and brian tampa oh no
all right thank you i got so excited
about talia
he will be though the good news is i fly
into detroit and i drive an hour to
toledo
uh guys funny bone toledo ohio may 28th
29th 30th
get your tickets and then we got san
antonio texas
lol june 3rd the 5th i'm staying at the
hotel emma i'm going to need you to help
me out
um you got your boy there i do all right
let's see what i can do and then albany
new york the funny bone june 18 19.
so you get them go get your tickets
philadelphia and then june 4th and 5th
appleton wisconsin skyline comedy club
chapelle lacy headline and skyline comic
club
i'm excited man it feels good headlining
man it really does you belong you're a
headliner man
yeah feels great tickets for all three
of us at f-a-t-k-z.com
this friday new thick boy merch drops
new hoodies long sleeves
tees it's not on there that's the old
stuff new stuff drops this friday
thickboy.com uh friday morning
friday morning bunch of sold out isn't
it all right yep i'm gonna thick boy
gear cummins thick boy summer get it
while you can
stay thick this is the fire in the kids
we're out boom gabon